to our top story of the new year more
revelations of a shadowy alleged
conspiracy involving NATO the UK Foreign
Office and British intelligence they
appear to show the UK government leading
a massive operation to control politics
and public opinion files suspected of
being hacked and leaked from a British
Institute that aims to counter Russian
propaganda was big news for Kremlin
funded media channels Britain has in
fact created a large-scale information
secret service in Europe but what if all
is not what it seems
and rather than concerned activist
hackers seeking to expose shadowy
British activities this was instead a
Russian state attack against this
retired civil servant and his
little-known Institute that receives UK
funding but says it's independent of the
British government Chris Donnelly has
little doubt the only thing which makes
sense is that this is the Russian state
attack against what we're doing and
which specific agency do you believe was
involved our assessment and it is that
because we don't have forensic proof
this is the GRU he was referring to the
military intelligence agency accused of
the attempted assassination of Sergey
and Ullaeus [ __ ] mr. donaly suspects
the GRU targeted the Institute for
statecraft in part as a response to
Britain calling out the Russian service
over the souls beast by poisoning
we know that the National Crime Agency
is now investigating the attack what do
you think of that it demonstrates that
the government clearly considered this
to be a significant attack by a hostile
foreign power against the UK his
Institute is registered at the Scottish
mill as a charity but its offices are in
London it does various projects
including Health Service and police
reform hacked files leaked online since
November focus on what the Institute
says is its program to combat
disinformation called the integrity
initiative the names of academics
journalists and other experts have also
been leaked the Foreign Office wouldn't
comment on attribution but noted past
Russian activities we've seen cyber
attacks of this sort growing as a fan
what we can see very clearly is that a
lot of this is linked to Russia security
sources say the Institute attack could
be the first Hacken Lee cooperation by
Russia against a British target a tactic
the GI use been accused of using
elsewhere but a spokesman for President
Vladimir Putin told Sky News we have
been saying numerous times that the
Russian state has nothing to do with any
cyber attacks the Institute for
statecraft is still managing the fallout
from the attack and expecting more leaks
Deborah Haynes Sky News